— Давайте, та ми ще не дуємо. Почекайте. Почекайте.
— Чекайте. Що ми сьогодні святкуємо?
Слово надається голові фонду. Офіціозно, так. Почекай.
Нам сьогодні один рочок. Один свідомий рочок.
З днем народження нас усіх!
Дякую дуже, що ви з нами витерпіли, особливо Лєну,
тому що вона — просто янгольський характер. [сміються]
Дякую, що ви з нами весь цей час допомагаєте,
підтримуєте і розвиваєте.
Ми з вами побачимося незабаром через тиждень там.
Все! Раз, два, три!
[задувають свічку, сміються]
Браво, браво!
[під оплески та вигуки]
Ура! Давайте слово надамо ще Назару,
нашому поважному гостю Назару. Назар, кажи.
Назар, чиє відео набрало 150 тисяч [переглядів]
на сайті «Повернись живим»!
Давай, кажи.
— Кажи, що ти бажаєш.
— Бажаю...
Щоб ви вилікували дітей, які...
— Які що?
— Які живуть...
Які живуть... Які живуть...
[усі сміються]
— Де вони живуть? Де ми живемо?
— На фронті.
[ледь чутно] Соромиться.
Мій тато в 1990-х роках шукав роботу,
тому що в Азербайджані роботи не було.
Тоді всі починали торгувати — як ПП — підприємці.
Він їздив, привозив якісь товари, продавав тут, їздив у Москву,
всі родичі просили його брати з собою, показувати, як це робити.
Він ніколи не був особливо бізнесменом,
але він намагався щось робити.
І потім він приїхав в Україну, у Донецьк,
йому там сподобалось, він там залишився.
Він побачив, що місцеві дуже нормально
реагують на приїжджих.
І він відкрив там кілька кіосків, залишився.
І потім покликав сім'ю, маму й мене туди.
Це був 1994 рік. І я прожив у Донецьку
десь років 15 чи 14, десь так.
Це, до речі, наш танк.
Цю машину подарували Лєні кілька років тому.
Нам сюди чи туди, Лєн? Здається, туди.
— Так? Тут же можна ліворуч?
— Угу.
Подарували, коли вона була волонтеркою,
і цій машині років 30, вона постійно потрапляє…
— 20!
— 20? Ну добре, 20, на 15 років молодша за мене.
Її звати Ґолді, інколи ми називаємо
Ґолді Олд Маєр, Олд Майті.
Загалом, всемогутня Ґолді.
Тому що вона виживала після обстрілів,
ви побачите там дірки повсюди.
Після прямих попадань, після пісків, пантонів.
Нещодавно ми дали їй друге життя.
Вона вмерла, коли довезла нас
три місяці тому до Києва, а потім все, пішла від нас.
І от зараз добрі люди допомогли її відновити.
Це єдина машина фонду, з якою ми добираємося
по фронту, тому що там інакше не проїхати ніяк.
А це, виходить, мені було… 1994 рік з 1985 року?
Вісім років десь було. Я тоді вчився в третьому класі.
Як приїхав сюди, пішов в школу,
зрозуміло, що російської мови не знав.
У Донецьку всі спілкувалися російською мовою,
і школа була російською мовою.
І коли я сидів на першій парті, і вчителька казала:
[російською] «Відкриваємо дужечки, пишемо те і те...».
Я писав: [російською] «Відкриваємо дужечки...».
Тобто я не знав, що це означає, і нічого не розумів
перший час, і тому мене відправили до репетитора.
І ось вона була закохана в українську мову.
Це вона мене почала вчити української мови,
навіть більше, ніж російської,
хоча ми спочатку йшли до неї вчитися російської мови.
Я пам'ятаю такий випадок. До неї приходила ще одна дівчинка
з мамою, і в якийсь момент мама тієї дівчинки сказала:
«Та я навіть не вчила би свою дитину української мови».
І ця вчителька, їй було десь під 70 років,
попросила дівчинку вийти в кухню і сказала мамі:
«Забирайте свою доньку і не повертайтесь сюди ніколи».
Вона дуже полюбляла українську мову,
дуже поважала. А я залишився.
Їй було приємно, що приїхав азербайджанець
і вчить українську мову.
Це ериванська група азербайджанських килимів.
Тому що азербайджанські килими
діляться на групи регіональні.
Колись це було Ериванське ханство, і в нього є своя група.
Бачиш які. Я взагалі обожнюю наші килими.
Дуже обожнюю, така фанатка.
І мрію, щоб у мене в колекції їх було більше.
Поки що один килим у мене.
Але мрію, щоб...
Щодо того, як азербайджанці опинилися в Україні,
нараховують декілька хвиль.
Це, здається, десь у сімдесятих роках
в Азербайджані була така політика,
коли направляли азербайджанську молодь, абітурієнтів
(це, власне, така державна програма була),
до різних країн, щоб вони отримували знання
в інших республіках — тоді ще радянських.
І цей досвід... Щоб вони набралися свого досвіду і різноманітності,
накопичували і потім привозили цей ціннісний досвід в Азербайджан.
Але хтось повертався, хтось залишався.
Інша хвиля – це пов'язано із карабаською війною,
коли був потік біженців, це початок 1990-х років.
Ну й наші роки, це приїжджають дуже багато
студентів навчатися в Україні.
І азербайджанські абітурієнти обирають Україну
як країну для отримання вищої освіти.
Усе, що я бажав в університеті, – це швидше закінчити
університет і переїхати в Київ.
Але ви маєте розуміти, що в азербайджанській родині
вирватись із родини дуже важко.
Тобто всі думають, що ти зараз, якщо вийдеш з дому,
тебе там вб'ють, вкрадуть… Це не стосується навіть [тільки] дівчат.
І це треба дуже довго боротися, щоб вийти з родини
і нарешті поїхати кудись далі.
Тому що за 14 років проживання в Донецьку
я жодного разу нікуди не виїжджав майже.
І зараз мені це дивовижно розуміти,
що, ну, як так сталося.
Зараз я в рік мандрую більше,
ніж за всі оці роки, які я там жив.
Клас!
Це скільком? Це один? На одну терапію чи скільки?
— На жаль, коробочки немає. Можу розділити на два.
— Давайте, давайте.
Так, ми взяли на один курс арт-терапії. Це на 15 дітей.
Один курс — це десять занять.
Тому їм вистачить десь може на два місяці.
Тобто одне заняття в тиждень.
І коли воно починається, наприклад, от, дивіться.
Коли вони починають малювати, перший день курсу,
то там більше чорних кольорів, а під кінець — більше яскравих, світлих.
Тому що вони все це виплескують.
Там нічого такого прям... Вони не проходять
на арт-терапії якусь психологічну допомогу.
Просто дітям дають можливість
висловити все, що в них всередині.
Чим більше вони малюють під наглядом психолога,
звичайно, тим під кінець навіть фарби, кольори міняються.
Ми зараз веземо. Ми будемо везти самі цього разу.
Зазвичай ми відправляємо «Новою Поштою»,
і там наша координаторка приймає і роздає теж по місцевостях.
А цю ми будемо везти самі, тому що через тиждень самі туди їдемо.
І тому ми привеземо самі цю посилку.
Там поки що вистачить на один тиждень, ще залишилися.
Я буду наливати чай і одразу буду розповідати,
що це традиційна форма для чаювання.
Вона називається азербайджанською «армут».
Армут — це груша, і ви бачите одразу, що вона має форму груші.
Але вона має і практичне значення:
тому що коли ти наливаєш чай і ось тут,
коли ти п'єш, у тебе залишається
чай однакової температури.
Тому що він тут ще гарячий,
а тут вже не такий гарячий, але він компенсується.
І тому ти завжди п'єш чай однієї температури,
для тебе комфортної.
Можна сказати, що приблизно так виглядає
азербайджанський стіл для чаювання.
Це чай. Він трохи світліший, тому що я знаю, що мої азербайджанці
будуть дивитися і скажуть: «Що це за світлий чай такий налила?».
Я тут додала траву з Азербайджану, гірську траву.
Вона називається «кеклікоту». Нашою це – чебрець.
Але він дуже ароматний, тому він трошки світліший,
ніж класичний чай, який більш темний.
На класичному азербайджанському столі
для чаювання зазвичай присутні:
кілька видів варення (це все мама моя робила), солодощі,
у нашому випадку – це традиційна бакинська пахлава,
це можуть бути якісь такі перекуси, ізюм, горіх тут має бути.
Відносини України й Азербайджану носять дуже…
У них є дуже класне історичне підґрунтя.
Тому що це не відносини, які почалися в період
незалежності обох країн. Вони мають свою історію.
Ну якщо так дуже далеко не заходити: початок ХХ століття,
коли була утворена УНР — Українська Народна Республіка
і АДР — Азербайджанська Демократична Республіка.
Перші контакти, навіть офіційні, вже почалися тоді.
Країни мали дипломатичні представництва: і в Баку, і в Україні
у нас були дипломатичні представництва АДР.
Тому ця історія йде дуже глибоко.
Наші держави, Україна й Азербайджан, є стратегічними партнерами.
Це дуже високий рівень комунікації держав між собою.
У нашій останній Стратегії національної безпеки України
Азербайджан позначений як одна з небагатьох країн,
яка позначена як стратегічний союзник.
Ми намагаємося різними шляхами зацікавити
людей допомагати проводити арт-терапію.
Зараз насправді люди якось втомилися від проблем,
від негативу, і ми намагаємося позитивно приносити ідею.
Ми зробили передріздвяний аукціон: ми просимо
наших підопічних на Сході робити прикраси ялинкові,
а потім виставляємо на аукціон у фейсбуку,
і люди беруть участь, і всі кошти йдуть на арт-терапію.
От ми зробили своїми силами перший аукціон.
І дуже класно там боротьба йшла між різними людьми,
і навіть підключилася Німеччина, чоловік посів друге місце…
— А перше місце?
— А перше місце, що прикольно...
— За перше місце боролася жінка, яка проживає в Зайцевому…
— Сама з Горлівки…
— Сама з Горлівки, так, вона виїхала туди.
— Лєна Павлова.
І вона чотири рази піднімала пропозицію і таки виграла.
Ми з 2014 року, як тільки почалася війна, ми почали їздити на Схід.
Мене... Це була перша чи друга група
від «П'ятого каналу», яка поїхала на Схід.
У нас тонесенький бронік і тонесенький шолом.
І ми були під час звільнення Слов'янського,
там ми їздили по всьому фронту.
Потім я почав працювати там з іноземцями,
а потім я почав робити там фільм теж з іноземцем.
І коли ти так працюєш довгий час,
то розумієш, що ти хочеш не просто приїхати, зняти і поїхати,
і отримати фестивальну нагороду і все, а ти там хочеш щось внести.
Ура, ура, ура! Все приїхало.
Нам прислали шість ялинкових прикрас, хоча ми просили одну.
Але ця дівчинка зробила шість.
Ой-йой-йой... Тримай.
Це тут? Вау!
Дві з них уже куплені на аукціоні.
І всі гроші підуть на арт-терапію.
А ще дві от...
Краса, вау! А як їх так взяти обережно, щоб не...
— Ще треба буде попрацювати з нею.
— І там ще таких шість балерин різних.
— Це ж цю купили чи яку?
— Здається, да.
Найприкольніше те, що члени нашої команди самі боролися,
теж хотіли купити, а я їх ледь стримував.
Я інколи жартую з друзями, кажу,
що любов до України інколи дуже болісна,
тому що мені то руку ламають,
то обстрілюють, то ще щось трапляється.
А 2013-2014 роки — це були важкі роки
не тільки для мене, а й для всіх українців.
І 2013-2014 рік я пишався тим, що я нарешті ось тут, тут.
Хоча був журналістом, але я розумів, де добро, а де — зло.
Я не шкодую жодного дня, який я провів там, і що я зробив.
Я не вважаю, що ми щось упустили.
Тобто все не змінюється в країні
за одну революцію і за дві не змінюється.
Я впевнений, що такого, як у Білорусі чи в Росії,
у нас ніколи більше не буде, бо в нас люди не бояться.
І за це я люблю і поважаю українців, що коли тут,
в Україні, б'ють одного, на його захист виходять сотні людей.
На жаль, я про інші пострадянські країни
так не можу сказати зараз.
Ну, хіба що в Грузії — там теж була така революція.
Я маю на увазі зараз не Прибалтику, а ці країни.
Тобто за це я дуже полюбив українців,
що вони завжди борються за свою волю, за свою свободу.
Це таке відчуття, розуміння, що «вау, я належу до частинки цього народу».
І це дуже круте відчуття.
[російською] Все!
— [російською] Ти виграв?
— [російською] Так!
Та блін!
Можна я, можна я?
На одному з аукціонів, найпершому,
Олена Євгенівна п'ять разів перебивала ціну.
Змагалася з чиновниками, з губернаторами. Вони програли.
Змагалася зі всіма і виграла.
Я не знаю, останні ставки вона вже вночі ставила?
І ми були вражені. Я пишу Лєні:
«Це та сама Олена Євгенівна, з Зайцева? Точно? Це вона?»
«Ну так, це вона». Я кажу: «Нічого собі».
Отже, ми довезли вам... Причому це довга історія:
дитина прислала нам, а ми привезли з Києва. Ось.
Цю ялинкову прикрасу.
Дякуємо вам дуже, що брали участь.
Це від Альони лист.
Дякую за завзяту боротьбу і виграш. [аплодують]
— Дуже дякую!
— Ууууу! [аплодують]
— Але чекаємо фото, на ялинці.
— Фото на ялинці, прекрасно.
— А де лист від Альони?
— А ось, так!
У мене немає дилеми щодо самоідентифікації.
Я — азербайджанка, я почуваюся азербайджанкою.
Я знаю, що я азербайджанка.
Але я — громадянка України.
У мене це дуже потужно поєднано одне з одним.
Я патріотка, я дуже люблю Україну.
І в своїй діяльності — навіть якщо це
Спілка азербайджанської молоді України —
дуже велику частину нашої діяльності ми присвячуємо Україні.
Я так само щасливий, що я азербайджанець,
що я не повністю українець, що я наполовину азербайджанець.
Бо це мені дуже допомагає в житті.
І ще я думаю, що найголовніше, що мені дала моя нація –
це не втрачати позитивність.
Тому що у нас навіть є муган – пісні.
Такі пісні, коли починають дуже журливо співати,
а потім переходять на танці.
Це така ментальність, що як би погано не було –
залишайся на позитиві.